[Music]
meagan Marco is loving life as a royal
it's been over a month since the former
suit start tied the knot with Prince
Harry and the Duchess of Sussex is
already eager to dive into her new role
headfirst would be the adventure of a
lifetime a source tells et that megan
has quote been anxious to jump in and
learn as much as possible and will spend
a great deal of time in the coming
months representing the royal family
adding she's ready to work as much as
she can on as many projects as they will
allow according to our source the royal
family is impressed by Megan and her
genuine desire to engage in charitable
projects much like Harry's late mother
Princess Diana it isn't enough to simply
talk about equality one must believe in
it the source adds that she has already
been having secret meetings with various
charities adding that her work will
focus on quote gender equality girls
education gay rights and human rights
much like the work she did as a
representative for the oneworld
Foundation and as a UN advocate women
need a seat at the table they need an
invitation to be seated there